[Musik]
das ist wieder der Anfang noch das Ende
von John bürkis Geschichte als
Jugendlicher tickt er nicht so wie es
Eltern und Schulbehörde verlangten
schlussendlich stand er da ohne
Schulabschluss so endete der Film der
nicht 2011 über John gedreht hatte wie
sieht sein Leben heute aus davon handelt
diese Reportage
[Musik]
der zwölf Jahre alte Film über johnny
ist noch immer Thema an verschiedenen
Schulen heute ist der Gast in einer
Abschlussklasse
und ja
die Klasse hat viele Fragen anschauen
Lehrerin Michaela sammelte sie und trägt
sie vor wenn du noch was zurück an die
Oberstufe könntest was würdest du anders
machen ich würde
ich bin in der Schweiz
weniger wichtig sind aber die haben mich
damals habe ich mir beschäftigt
und
und Du darfst wahrscheinlich auch nie
wirklich gross Interesse entwickelt für
Joule oder für fürs Lernen für Prüfungen
die meisten Prüfungen
und darum nachher schlecht
der 16-Jährige John kehrt nach einem
mehrwöchigen timeo zurück in die
sekundar-klasse werden
aufgrund zahlreiche Verstöße gegen die
Schulordnung
und wird da wieder werden und
konsumieren
im Unterricht ist schon nicht ganz bei
der Sache
Spielzeuge werden soll
ich sagen wir steigen in die Pause
sein Verhalten
einmal mehr redet sie dem Jugendlichen
ins Gewissen schon
zwei Minuten
John möchte Grafiker lernen durch mit
schlechten Schulnoten eine Lehrstelle zu
finden ist schwierig bisher reiht sich
Absagen Absage um seine Chancen zu
vergrößern bewirbt er sich als
detailhandelsverkäufer das ist für ihn
keine Herzensangelegenheit
dementsprechend hält sich seine
Motivation in Grenzen
kann das jetzt zwei drei Jahre
parallel zum Bewerbungsschreiben
[Musik]
dass meine der Befehl aber ich kann eben
eine Musik lassen und Hausaufgaben
machen und lernen also
das ist halt für mich eine Beschäftigung
oder wann bin ich gerade online und weiß
wann wäre
woanders
zu gleichen Zeit im Wohnzimmer nebenan
Johns Stiefvater Zorn
die Aufzeichnung zeigt eine
Massenveranstaltung einer ungarischen
Freikirche bei der auch der Kroate
Mitglied ist
macht mich richtig leidenschaftlich
christliche Werte will ich auch seinem
Stiefsohn vermitteln und dazu eine
Anleitung zum beruflichen Erfolg
wichtige Frage was macht ihr was macht
mir echte Freude wo ich in meine
einzigartigen Stärken was will ich in
meinem Leben erreichen du das immer
wieder dich selber fragen
[Musik]
interessant die sagt die Sache mit der
Lehrstelle Prozess halt so nicht später
bevor er raus darf gibt es noch ein
gemeinsames Abendessen
arbeitet als kundenassistentin in einer
Bank die gebürtige Brasilianerin ist für
den Familienunterhalt zuständig ihr
Ehemann verdient ein Zubrot als
zeitungsverträge der ehemalige
Personalberater gab seinen Vollzeitjob
auf um sich mehr mit dem Glauben
auseinanderzusetzen
[Musik]
vor der Abschlussklasse im ST gallischen
Buchs erzählt schon wie er damals das
Familienleben empfand
[Musik]
und das ist für mich nicht so einfach
sie will ich habe mich damals gefühlt
wäre oder als campen und
sobald man der Kontrolle
meinte mir möchte mit Klapse beschritz
ins Gesicht zeigen
und ich bin absolut nicht empfänglich
sie für das und das mit der Hausaufgabe
okay ich bin nicht wirklich allein
gemacht
ich bin einfach nicht gern
[Musik]
der 16-Jährige schon steht von allen
Seiten unter Druck
nur zu seinem leiblichen Vater den er
selten sieht ist die Beziehung locker
[Musik]
der 47 Jahre alte Roger Bürki ist
Finanzberater und hat das zwei
gescheiterten Beziehungen drei Kinder
John wünscht sich beim Vater einzuziehen
[Musik]
ist nach Brasilien ausgewandert
August
[Musik]
macht man sich als Elternteil natürlich
immer dass wir das mit wenig Zeit für
Personen
ich muss natürlich auch sagen ich habe
zwei weitere Kinder
und auch
immer so richtig
Challenge herausfordern
hat einfach gemacht
gut
danke tschüss
dann mit dem älter werden gemerkt dass
dass ich
verpasst hat also verpasst
und Küste von genüsslicher
aber
immer lustig sind
das natürlich absolut cool
auf der anderen Seite natürlich
Herbst im Jahre 2010 im aargauischen
Bier findet deine Krisensitzung statt es
geht um John eingeladen sind seine
geschiedenen Eltern Vater Roger Bürki
nimmt zum ersten Mal an einem älteren
Gespräch Teil Lehrerin Susanne Jumper
kritisiert das Verhalten des
Jugendlichen
mein Mann hat ein bisschen mehr drauf
geachtet
wobei die Dinge die ich zuletzte fahren
habe dass er gemacht hat das hat mich
wirklich erstaunt das ist so weit
gekommen ist
John wurde auf dem Schulhaus von einer
Überwachungskamera gefilmt die Eltern
erfahren ist jetzt was er konkret
angestellt hat
die Kamera
die Schulleitung hat den Jugendlichen
wegen Sachbeschädigung angezeigt
sehr komfortabel
[Musik]
dann geht es keine richtige Antwort
nächstes befriedigend ist die Zeit ist
zu knapp morgen zum 5:07 Uhr darüber zu
reden und dann mal mit mag ich nicht
wie war es für dich als deine Mutter an
den Elterngesprächen geweint hatte
ich glaube damals
nicht deshalb kam es daheim zu einer
heftigen Auseinandersetzung mit John
Stiefvater
was ist denn genau
zwei Wochen lang hatte zur polizeilich
verordnet das Hausverbot weil er den
Stiefsohn geschlagen hatte
Johns Mutter hat ihn angezeigt nun ist
der Kroate wieder daheim
Konflikt mit sich selber einerseits sind
sie sehr religiös auf der anderen
alkoholisiert der Vater bin und
frustriert einfach drei schlau und oder
John hast das ist nichts Motiv Motiv ist
ja dass ich gesehen das Gespräch und ähm
verbindliche Sachen wo man abspricht
Energie kalte werden und dann
ist es so dass sie halt einmal
oder mehr
trotz schwieriger Vergangenheit trifft
sich schon heute noch regelmäßig mit
seinem Stiefvater und der Mutter
vieles ist ausdiskutiert und geklärt
worden
ja ich kann Fehler gemacht und das
stiefvatere kann ich druck aufgesetzt
und und haben einfach
das zu unterschätzt dass schon sehr
sensibel ist dass man da eigentlich
ja Geduld haben mit jungen Leute
das ich bin nicht empfänglich aktiv für
gut gemeint die Aussatz wo du zueinander
verfolgt hast das hat
Unverständnis gesorgt und dann hast du
vielleicht mittlerer Griffe damals so
für mich wiederum ja nicht singt sie und
das hat sich das ganz oft gefragt dich
habe ich nur immer als Opfer gesehen und
sogar und ich bin deine Miete gestanden
und wusste nicht wo ich mich
positionieren kann
das heißt wirklich eine
[Musik]
und und und
bewusst haben
in dem ganzen ist ja uns alle vergeben
und wir uns selbst wunderschön
[Musik]
im Mai 2011 singt Johns Motivation in
jeder Hinsicht auf den Nullpunkt das
wird im 16-Jährigen zum Verhängnis nach
dem Unterricht sind er und seine Mutter
von der Schulleitung zu einem Gespräch
geladen
zu dem Gespräch wo für nicht einfach ist
[Musik]
nervöset alle sehr genau den Situation
ist nicht einfach aber wir können dir
auch nicht helfen
aber
anders
relativ
offensichtlich konsumierte
und das ist ganz klarer Verstoß gegen
diese Regeln und vor allem gegen die
Schulregeln und zu mir jetzt halt
konsequenziert und sagen nach der
frühlingserie du bist Leitungen
aber der beendet doch oder nein er
beendet nicht
und im Prinzip hat mir das schon lange
machen aber
es ist für mich schon mit schwerer
[Musik]
Personen
ja schöne ganz einfach
[Musik]
mit mir und
nur noch drei Wochen hätten gefehlt bis
zum Ende der Schuljahres nun steht er da
als schulversorge ausgeschlossen vom
Unterricht ohne Abschluss
[Musik]
Film gemacht
ja unterwegs
sind
langweilig so nach zwei Monaten
mitmachen und so habe
[Musik]
mich beworben in Burger King und da
einfach mal oder Kasse beim Burger King
geschaffen kann
mit 20 absolviert er die Rekrutenschule
anschließend diente sich bis zum
Oberwart Meister hoch zum ersten Mal
realisiert er dass er für sein Leben die
Verantwortung selbst übernehmen muss
noch
einmal besonders
[Musik]
schon besucht eine kaufmännische Schule
und findet anschliessend
[Musik]
mit meinem Hund und im Sache verzählen
zum Thema Versicherung
seit drei Jahren arbeitete bei einem
Bekannten Versicherungsunternehmen ein
Gespräch mit einer Kundin steht an
verschiedenen momentan
und ich würde sagen das mit dem gleichen
Zug auch gerade
zentral um die betriebsratsschutz
gegangen
vor allem Selbstständige
Unternehmerinnen
gerade aufgrund seiner Vergangenheit
seit schon im Beruf erfolgreich
ein spezieller Moment schon trifft nach
Jahren seine ehemalige inzwischen
passionierte Lehrerin Susanne
t
nach längerer
mit dabei sind aus Stefan Widmer und
sind die Fersch alle drei besuchten vor
12 Jahren dieselbe Abschlussklasse
[Musik]
seit Ende der Schulzeit ist es der erste
Besuch im ehemaligen Klassenzimmer
Biologie
Stefan Widmer lernte Straßenbauer und
arbeitet noch heute auf diesen Beruf
sind die Ferse ist Fachfrau
Kinderbetreuung zurzeit macht sie die
Berufsmatur und will danach Psychologie
studieren am frühsten
Situation
probiert viel gemacht mit wählerhaufen
und ich habe es einfach ein schlimme
Situation für ihn gefunden und ich
einfach immer so gut wie möglich weil
helfe ist das richtig sieht schon drei
Wochen
es ist einfach konsequent
irgendeine stimmen müssen
Konsequenzen
auch immer ist es geht ganz hoch von
anderen Johnson oder Girls
Mama muss sagen
und wenn dir immer nicht respektiert
wird und zu Staffel vorher nicht sagen
Glück mir ist ein Problem danke
[Musik]
vor der Schulklasse im ST gallischen
Buchs spricht er zum Abschluss über
seine Karrierepläne
mit jüngster Erfolg sage ich mal ist
die
erste berufsspezifische Prüfung mit
guter schriftliche Prüfung
und das ist für mich ein normal völlig
was anderes wie damals
in Zukunft noch erwähnlich als zwei
Bilder darauf
Psychologie ich überlege mir im Moment
habe ich Schulbank nochmal
und dem Nachgang
doch am meisten fasziniert und das wäre
das wäre Option vielleicht das Studium
probiere jetzt machen und zweiten ich
weiß auch nicht Gedankenspiel ist
richtig Selbstständigkeit
in der Schule wollte John Bürki nicht
lernen aber danach verstanden die
Lektion ihm das Leben gab
[Musik]